listen we've tried to have this
discussion about the Chappell a46 thing
it's been very difficult high stakes
because you don't want to criticize it
because it seems like you're criticizing
the thing that he's supporting right so
it's very difficult to detach this from
detach the art from the point that he's
making because there's not a lot of art
in it right it's not if it was stand up
you could criticize the stand up jokes
but it's not stand up he's just talking
about what's happening right now in our
country and he's saying things and
speaking eloquently on it
so you don't want to criticize it
because it seems like you're criticizing
his point of view instead of criticizing
the way that he's delivering it right is
that fair yeah yeah that that's why I
think it's so harsh right so I think the
reaction a lot of people have and I
think we agreed to look at this through
two lens lenses one is our reaction to
the piece and the other is our reaction
to people's reactions to the piece yes
right and it's really difficult because
we're we're jaded in a way because our
expectation from Chappelle is so [ __ ]
great nothing less than mastery is
accept is accepting if you are putting
every point forward masterfully yeah
it's not your pal and also keep this in
mind for people who are listening a lot
of you guys haven't been in a room and
watched Dave Chappelle for six hours
straight like Akash and I have an Alex
has and I think in LA you did it or is
it you know it's in LA right and Mark I
don't know if you ever saw a long set
from Chappelle but like it's a mainland
it is unreal his ability to like control
a room and honestly control expectation
and patience you're not bored he could
talk for six hours and not bored
in our cos you were kind of bringing
this up with the special or not the
special with this peace with this talk
that he gave eight for six which was I
thought it was good overall but I was
born in the middle there were neighbors
hearts and that's kind of and some of
his points I'm like
now that's that's the week that's the
smoke you gave Canada's owns the Candice
own smoke wasn't like your [ __ ] stinks
undeniably week and again it's so weird
to even sit here and like criticize it I
almost feel like the only reason we're
talking about this is because it was
exalted by the people so that's I think
the issue and I think some of us had a
bigger issue with it than others yeah
Miha makes yeah and I this is
hypocritical go comics are like this is
what comedy should be this is whatever
I thought it was a good special it isn't
that a good comedy special it's not
comedy it was a good time and I will let
Dave Chappelle do this because I respect
his brilliance and he has the
credibility built up if you're some
[ __ ] loser at an open mic this is not
what comedy is in the same way we do not
let Hannah Gatsby slide and say that's
comedy that's not comedy neither is this
right exactly the criticism of a Hannah
Gatsby would be like the people who
agree with everything she's saying love
her and the people who don't agree are
gonna go well it's not funny enough for
me to not agree and the amazing thing
about comedy is that when a joke is
funny you cannot agree with the point of
view but it's so funny you're willing to
digest it you know it's like it's like
when you make like a horrible food out
of like sugar yeah you know how like
sometimes people make up like a boot at
a cake right right you know I'm talking
about it's like oh [ __ ] I'm eating a
boot but I'm not like that's what comedy
can be it can be this like sugary
encasing for this thing that you would
never eat in your life right and I think
maybe I was waiting for him to say stuff
in a way that was so unimpeachably that
people who completely disagreed with the
support of black lives matter and the
support of this movement to like and
police brutality and like give black
people the Equality they're supposed to
have I was waiting for him to put
forward these masterful arguments and
mm-hmm
I didn't see it based on a Chappelle
level of mastery like I like the Eric
Dorner comparison I thought that was
really clever this idea of like and that
is like a glimpse of what Chapelle does
he's like oh sorry
it's Eragon or Chris Dorner yeah so it's
like that's what he'll do he'll take
something and he'll go and he'll make
you empathize let's say you're super
supportive of the police
take that empathy you have for the
police and he'll find a way to position
that for his person that might be your
enemy right and he did that and greatly
this is the first time on stage and
months I think that if he had another
three weeks with that joke or that idea
that's a hilarious bit I don't even
think rust is ever an issue for him I
think he is well put it there's a
difference in time working out of Joe so
I think he didn't even have the time he
I think he felt like he needs to say
something now and he's had three weeks
to come up with bits about this right
right but so I wouldn't say 87 days
that's a he has to put up content in
what 21 days regardless regardless like
if that's your first time on stage yeah
just for people who don't understand how
the body works yeah exactly so it's like
you start with an idea on stage and it's
not that funny but the idea is there
yeah and then it's just like a piece of
wood you slowly carve it and shape it
into a sculpture right and I feel like
we had like the wood right there
right and again it's like see and that's
a thought that I had that it just came
to me now yeah you two are looking at it
from comics POV yeah I was just I'm just
like a fan right and so I thought it was
a little bit better than what you guys
think of course I don't think it's
chappelle's best piece but I also don't
look at this as a comedy special I just
look at this like a public speaking
event yeah and as he talks on the issues
going on and then he just throws a
little funny just to keep you you know
engage with it yeah I agree looking at
it from that point of view I thought it
was okay like I didn't hear anything new
that I didn't already I did think those
gusy such as a great order it's like I
was glued to and that to your point at
the bee anthem in the middle I was like
you know this is he's losing me and at
the end and it I've said this y'all
memorable times now but this really have
hit me when he talked about you know
George Floyd callin for his mom and then
his dad he's only heard that one of the
time his dad calling for his grandma and
at the end he says my dad's grandma was
a slave and like the recency of that
[ __ ] stuck with me yeah yeah and again
we all no one knows how long ago slavery
was we all kind of put it 400 years ago
300 years ago 200 years ago that I was
like holy [ __ ] slavery was
and recent like a slave or not let's
separate water fountains I'm talking
about no water in the fields mad reason
so like that affected me in a way that I
was like [ __ ] and that made it worth it
for me
mm-hmm so I think I'm a little less
harsh because I hadn't maybe I just
don't know history at all I don't really
care too but that put it in a way to me
that was like [ __ ] because if it was
released by Ted if it was a TED talk
yeah your reaction be different no it
isn't yeah because what I what I miss
from it were prolific arguments and I'm
used to him making such prolific
arguments within his stand-up for me and
our Casa and I might debate this word
but like when I see the arguments in his
stand-up I'm like that logic is so
unimpeachable did I could present that
to the most right-wing person or the
most left-wing person person and both of
them will sit there and go now I got a
point
and I what I saw here was raw emotion
and sometimes you need to speak off
emotion I'm not saying there isn't a
place for that but what Chappelle did so
beautifully I think in his career was
like took that emotion and then carved
it into these like beautiful arguments
that did a lot of the intellectual heavy
lifting for the people that will listen
and watch them and then you could take
those arguments and then you could use
them when you're debating your uncle who
might not really be empathetic to this
struggle and I just didn't really see
that here so if that was a TED talk I'd
be like there was enough Ted what I saw
was you know saying there was enough Ted
in it so it was just a talk then I
thought wasn't up to the standard of
brilliance that Chappelle has and if
those arguments were made funny I'd be
like all right it was cool I laughed it
was really but then he didn't really put
the effort to make them funny so it was
missing brilliance and missing funny and
I think I went into it I think I went
into it cuz I saw the way people are
reacting to it you gotta see this is the
greatest thing ever
that you this will never be not spoken
about and it's no different than when
you go into a movie and people say it's
amazing and you're like Wayne it wasn't
it the greatest movie I've ever seen and
now it seems like a letdown cuz my
expectations were so hot you know so two
things that's a big difference actually
because my the first things comics sent
me like Robbie Slovak Elektra
like it's not comedy still watch it yep
and then my girl had time to watch it
before me and she was like she said the
Hannah gasps do you think she's like all
right don't [ __ ] on Hannah gasping like
this and I was like okay so it's not
gonna be funny and I know this you went
in with the writer so I went in okay
it's not gonna be funny and in the
middle I was like yo she might be right
I might have to give Hennig I might have
to give Chapelle that Hannah Gatsby
smoke yeah and then at the end maybe I
was so relieved there was something I
could grab on today I was like thank God
okay but two theories about why it
wasn't carved out as beautifully as we
would have hoped yeah mine is time he
just didn't have time you felt like I
have to say something the country's at a
[ __ ] breaking point yeah two is
Alex's theory that he presented earlier
and say that on the mic what the editing
and all that like what he has in store
oh yeah I really feel that he had a
performance a full stand-up performance
and this was like the end of the
performance where it's like he just
talks to the crowd so it's like he
wasn't trying to deliver jokes and
something that stuck with me when al
said that is you know like very early
into the Chappelle set he goes hey y'all
bored yet hmm
we've all seen Chappelle when I see him
doing six hours he doesn't ask that [ __ ]
for four hours or y'all bored yet so for
him to say that eight minutes in or
whatever I remember at the time being
like this Matt early for Chappelle to
ask if we're bored yep so that could be
he could have done a long set knock out
some [ __ ] and then at the end has been
emotional and that's all he put out
there I think that Chappelle is moving
towards and I've said this before just
speaking and like being like almost like
a teacher and like he has such prolific
thoughts that they he can just talk to
us about these things and we seen in the
past and I've seen him do it live etc I
just didn't see that prolific things
being said about this and and I look I
could be wrong but I asked you guys that
are you know listening to the podcast
like when you saw the arguments that he
laid out or what he was talking about
like was there something that you were
like you know I didn't look at it that
way outside of the of the Dorner what's
Chris Dorner Chris Dorner outside of the
Chris Dorner thing I was there something
that you were like again for me the end
the end the end the end the thing the
end I get why that resonated with you
because I remember once my dad was
telling me my dad did
a documentary on this on this guy I
forget I forget his name but he told a
story about he was this jazz musician
and he told a story about his mom
I believe his mom the jazz music super
old yeah I believe his mom seeing
Abraham Lincoln walk through DC that's
crazy after slavery was abolished and
she one of the last people to see this
do it now I'm wonder if it was his
grandma bye believed it was his mom this
guy's has already passed but when he
said that to me yeah I got that feeling
you got which was oh [ __ ]
yeah this is not that long ago yeah so
so maybe the reason that didn't affect
me in the same ways cuz I've heard that
story but Chappelle pudding in that way
I could see how it really invited you
and it can really put in context to
other people who are not sympathetic to
the black plight in America they're like
yeah why don't you get over that [ __ ]
it's like it's new still right okay I
see I see that I see that there
I don't know positives what are the
positives Chappelle said something
that's a positive yeah I thought the
Candice Owens point was actually pretty
decent like obviously the roast of her
was like it was trash but like when he
like Candice Owens raises this point
where she goes black people are the only
group people that sort of like exalt or
uphold the and make martyrs of the worst
of our the worst of our group yeah and
that we constantly like praise and make
t-shirts out of these people that are
criminals and you know yeah people and
like why do we choose these people and
then Chappelle says we don't choose them
you choose him the cops use them yeah
the cop I was a great point and I
probably forgot about because at that
point I was like this yeah you know
Candice Owens Rose was trash yep I would
almost rather hurt him not roast her
because it
I think clouded that point right and
then his only Rosenberg was like she's
so articulate and then the stinky [ __ ]
thing right right but like he was like
complimenting her at the same time I was
like I felt conflicted as to what he's
trying to say yo I'm on a lot Candice
handle that [ __ ] beautifully she's smart
dude she's not dumb
she now watch Chappelle says he's not
if y'all didn't see the way she handled
it she didn't like criticize she didn't
push back she was just like she's like -
every democrat tweeted me that clip with
Dave Chappelle insulted me I'm not a
left leftist I have a sense of humor I
think comics should make fun of people
Dave Chappelle is one of the greatest
comedians of all time I'm a it's one of
his specials that's power and then she
says some other [ __ ] like I hope that
you know we meet sometime you could say
that stuff to my face and then like
winky face smile but like she chose to
take the road oh I'm gonna laugh at this
allow it to happen instead of being all
butthurt yeah and then she actually
looks good yeah
coming out of it where's like if he
leaned into that idea and then leaned
into the caricature that she is and how
the right the Peter people on the right
hold her up as a token so that all of
her their arguments can be filtered
through her so that they can't be called
racist for having Candice Owens he has a
great opinion on Kenya so so why let's
hear that I know and I don't that I
agree with I agree with that it's like
what is at that point is a great point
we don't want these people to be our
heroes you do this that's a great point
you think he's saving it first and a bit
you think he's got like a bit because we
do that we're on the road we release
some of the stuff you know but we're
like nah don't keep that that's gonna be
a bit we're gonna put that in the next
special and maybe he has some real kin
to smoke but he's like you know let me
carve that out that's gonna be the one
that let you know puts the machete and
this could be proof I also thought this
could be proof as I was watching it of
what you've said which is I think he's
transitioning out of stand-up yes and I
think I don't think he is Malcolm or
Martin but I think when people say like
who's our guy he has the potential to be
one of those guys you know in that it
might not be the same level but that's
that's who we got right now and I think
this is him maybe getting comfortable
with stepping out of because there's
because humor for all of us is a defense
mechanism yes so maybe for him it was
let me get my points across through
humor and this is him kind of shedding
away the defense mechanism of humor and
it's let me just put forth my emotion yo
and we'll carve it out from there I like
I like that slow transition we've seen
him do it right he did it at the I think
Mark Twain yeah uh he did it uh he's
been doing it a bunch of different
places just kind of like talking
but also talking funny and I've always
said it's like I love Chapelle just be a
teacher yeah I don't think that this was
what he said was at the level of his
specials even a special like I would
rather listen to his arguments from his
specials without the punchlines
like I think some of the arguments in
the specialist without the punchlines
were so prolific even when he did the
bird revelation there weren't a lot of
punchlines in a she was incredible but
it was masterful
if you compare this to that there's a
different level of mastery going on we
can acknowledge that right that's gonna
sound blasphemous go but sticks and
stones wasn't up to the level of his
other stuff so is it just we got to
present all of the arguments that's to
me that's the goat the stones I remember
kind of thinking the same thing like
these aren't ideas I haven't heard
before and I expected more comedy
special from six and stones this I was
thinking like you weren't a fan of
sticks and stones I wasn't a massive fan
it was good and I'm glad she Pels the
guy carrying that torch forward it helps
all of us yeah but I remember thinking
we've said this stuff and Chapelle I I'm
not a genius by any stretch if I had the
same point of Chapelle I don't look at
me smarter I look at you pal like what
are you doing
I think sticks and stones it was a bar
when he said like he can't say maggot
but he could say [ __ ] on network execs
yeah yeah and she was like oh well you
can't say maggot because you're not gays
like well I'm also not a [ __ ] yeah but
a gay person could say the f-word and if
she said the same argument be like yeah
well I'm not an F word see what I'm
saying like it did the thing with that
joke is the argument on the surface
seemed great dissatisfied our emotions
but if you actually kind of like peel it
apart what so is the gay person an F
word yes he's not but he can say like
you have the license to use the bad
words that are attributed to you but you
don't have the license to use the bad
words they attribute to people who
aren't you but he phrase it as if she
was calling inward so she could kind of
like sacrifice her for the joke and I
thought the joke was really good and
this is one of the beautiful things
about stand-up it doesn't have to
the court of law that can be like a
really fun [ __ ] bit yeah and a great
point thanks a lot guys for yeah we
really ruined it for other people but
maybe that's also like the way that
that's a stain or we hold up to
Chappelle - for me yeah like I just
think he's the greatest living community
thank ya I think and I love Patrice but
just the Chappelle I just think gote
like I just do and yeah maybe Patrice is
right underneath him or whatever but
like I don't that doesn't take away from
his greatness it just that's what I saw
you're still great yeah and the thing
that was special about this if you want
to call it a special I'm not calling a
comedy if you want to call it a special
the thing that was special was he's Dave
Chappelle showing us a side of himself
he's never shown us right and the timing
and he spoke out and that's kind of what
made it special and that's that's it
right and I don't mean that like [ __ ]
this is a piece of trash but like if
we're gonna call it a special that's why
it's special and that's how I can
compartmentalize it cuz it wasn't
special in its content necessarily right
throughout it wasn't special in the fact
it was hilarious a people felt the need
especially our comics friends to like
talk about how prolific it was he's our
Trump man he's our Trump Oh like no
matter what he does is good yeah he's
like he's much and I'm not saying he is
Trump at all I think he's the greatest
but a trump supporter anything Trump
does is brilliant Chapelle did arm that
with us but anything he does is
brilliant
ah so we're looking at him through like
when he earned it that's different
Trump rose-colored glasses yeah and he
deserves it he's earned that yeah I
really believe like if a guy over eights
Chappell cool just don't think you got
the same license that's my only advice
to comics if you think this is what
comedy should be this is what Dave
Chappelle is allowed to be you are not
yeah you're gonna be asking if people
are bored a lot too
[Applause]